[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello
[Music]
yep I was rolling
rolling back down to my room
practicing my rolls absolutely
good morning
up
God I was testing it perfect
welcome good morning
[Music]
I'm ready to beat this thing today man
my day's just getting started it is 10
a.m here
ready to go all day
however long it takes
by the way if you guys are curious about
the music go check it out and go check
it out in the description it's Cthulhu
Seeker he did uh
a remix of a bunch of music from Elden
ring and it is absolutely awesome so
it's in the description if you want to
check out the Spotify playlist for
everything it's really cool
really really really cool
but we have work to do today don't we
we did beat Melania up I need my
controller hold on
controller acquired
there we go
but happy Monday
good morning good evening good afternoon
wherever you are from
let's get this [ __ ]
I'm ready bro
I'm freaking ready
do this thing
so last time we were here
last stream at the end of last stream
we've got radon
in phase one
of the fire Giant
right
and then we have astul
in the second second stage
which is actually pretty Epic
we can beat Redan pretty easy but astel
kind of glitches out a lot
making it pretty hard
pretty awkward I'd say
but we can do it
we gotta get to getting
no
no
oh
two hand
ow
okay I don't remember your moves right
now hold on
break
not a good start
I'm getting hit by everything right now
leave me alone
okay that's fine
never mind
my mimic's almost dead
nice
yeah health-wise we are not doing good
not good at all
what up pizza boy how are you oh God
all right our mimics dead that's bad
obviously
[ __ ] on
okay
not awful no we don't need the runes the
runes are
I think I already lost it before
okay now I gotta pull out
my stick oh [ __ ]
hit him with this
the only glitches out look at that
I don't know if my rocks hit him
oh God
God I hate that timing of that attack
that's what we want right there
right there
something take it
I'm terrified I don't know what he's
doing
excellent
okay that still hits the ground
come on nice
nice
see how this does
I think we should still hit his head
like normal
what is he doing there
okay let's hit this
excellent
nope I'm dead
oh come on here we go
awesome Fair
is he spawning in the same spot okay
not what I wanted
so he teleported into the exact same
spot just to spam his
meteor strike excellent
man
that was actually a good first attempt
though
not bad the radon fight could have been
much better
let's try that again
I had to pull out my stick man I was
missing my stick
you know my rock sling stick
yeah I think we should save the mimic
for astel I think that's a good idea
come here redone
I did not do hand yet
bruh
all right all right P indeed Andrew
thanks for the two dollars man
I just got owned
I'm struggling with radon somehow right
now I find radon to be quite easy
but thank you Andrew you're the man
appreciate it
I think it's just regular [ __ ]
because from what I've seen from this
one he doesn't do the uh
where he turns into a bunch of astols
I haven't seen that
which I think is the only difference
foreign
I think there's one other attack as well
it's definitely scaled to the fire giant
though
bruh why am I struggling with you
watch this is patch one radon
dude
ow
I am
I don't got this seven seven seven seven
seven seven seven seven seven
he didn't do the ads
thank you Brent
for the two dollars as well
thank you thank you
two super chats right at the start let's
go
only I wasn't playing like total dog
[ __ ] right now
I think you have to have the emote to do
the grilled cheese chain just saying
you don't even have the right emote
lame
what it I don't know what's happening
am I like too close or something I
remember just sticking on them and I'm
good
it's not working right now
great
where you at Dog
grilled cheese grilled cheese grilled
cheese grilled cheese grilled cheese
grilled cheese grilled cheese grilled
cheese grilled cheese grilled cheese
hold on thank you
dude
his moves are weird
get him right up in that crotch
excellent
okay I gotta wait I think because he's
just gonna shoot at me yep
do it again
mimic
Bang
I think we're good
let's get all these out
oh yeah baby okay here we go Andrew
thank you
[ __ ]
I have no healing again not not Bueno
is my mimic alive
I'm dead
it felt like I was dead I gotta be
really careful roxling takes a long time
nicer
come here
not worth
what was my mimic doing
there you are I never I never even saw
him
yes I was slightly distracted by the
grilled cheese
I'm not gonna lie
slightly distracted I'm better than that
though
thank you Andrew
he's kind of slacking not doing anything
I needed him to do
this is not easy boys
streamed two days ago she's these are
interesting that's good
good to hear red glad you like it
let me in
I have to attack it first
potentially I don't know
I thought the mimic just like went
toward the thing that's an Aggron
could be wrong
all right we need a better radon fight
obviously
foreign
still one-handing like a dummy
bruh dude
[Music]
that was Pro dodging right there
okay everything just hurts like 10 times
as much
[ __ ]
last time we did this when did we stream
Saturday
I was not struggling with radon at all
like I barely even got hit
and now I just get hit by everything
no we don't need a respect
absolutely not
I'm just I'm getting hit by basic
attacks this means I'm bad
damn Andrew
[Music]
thanks for becoming a member man
you guys are going crazy this morning
thank you
enjoy the emotes
right up in that booty hole
yeah that didn't hurt that bad
kill him
yes
Big Value there
where are you there you are
you little hoe
we went crazy there
foreign
okay whatever whatever wrong thing
he did that so much faster than he
usually does I'm sorry he just did
excellent
foreign
okay that's really weird
our summon is doing something I like
that
I'm a fan of him doing things
keep doing the things
stab his face
damn it
foreign
yes mimic
whoa chill
hi Trey good morning
oh
he wasn't even hurting our mimic
oh never mind
okay that freaked me out
looking at me
and that time you did it slower you did
it slower
our Minix AFK again come on
come on brother
go go go
nice
mimic
I don't like what you're doing
I thought I might stagger
that's too high
hit him with it
oh God
okay he seems to teleport to the same
spot every time
nice
get him
yeah man
I went for it watching the live streams
on all these six hours plus long drives
I've been doing all month BC my girls
Mars in the hospital and they really
have made us laugh or just giving back I
appreciate that Andrew and I'm glad I
can help in my weird way
I hope everything's okay that she gets
better and I appreciate the support
get some hearts in chat for Andrew thank
you man
[ __ ]
I think
I'm glad I can help man
my mimic is not here bro
I don't know how I dodged that
arts and chat hearts and chat thank you
Andrew
let's go mimic get in there buddy
we just gotta do this a couple times
except I'm out of FP now that is not
good
we gotta go in
dodged
run
okay I have some healing we're okay
keep it going
[ __ ]
same spot could be a grab no grab
what are you doing
get in there
he keeps smacking
it's okay
he's going a little brazy
come on man
I can't reach you
get down here
I just went for the big hit I think it
was worth it
son of a [ __ ]
the mimic is dead
son of a [ __ ]
I don't like this I don't like this
I hate them I think
I don't think I can dodge that last one
oh boys
You Gotta Get Lucky
where are you okay
foreign torrent run
oh
he's just spamming [ __ ] bro
[Music]
no
that was the
that was the worst thing he could have
done
no
he just oh
he did the normal Elden ring boss thing
all right
where they just Spam attacks when their
health is low
I swear that's a thing
along with input reading
I think I do have a Starlight
oh I have two
well
I think we'll be okay now we clearly got
this
if I run out we got it
nah we beat the fire Giant
easy peasy
what
never does this attack here
okay I would like it if those were to
stop
I think I'm dead
yeah just just reset
reset
yeah I know I could have used the
Starlight shards but I forgot
I am only human
I'm new here what did I miss nothing
much
just random bosses in random areas
and random items
spread everywhere
that's pretty much it
I can't believe how like hardcore I'm
getting bodied by radon
like I don't understand what's happened
I'm just bad
it's fine
go up into space idiot
I'm gonna summon him now
I don't know where he is oh [ __ ]
get a mimic
I think my mimic Knights
oh dude this is what happens when I
don't play Elden ring for a day I'm just
bad
now our weapon is at Plus 10.
we found a somber three
come come come come come come come
gosh I really thought we were gonna beat
[ __ ]
on that last good attempt okay thank you
tree for doing nothing
thank you tree
[ __ ]
I don't like saying that to radon
because I actually really like radon
he's definitely one of the Chads
[ __ ]
can anyone see because I can't
okay
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna spawn them
I'm not gonna use the mimic let's look
in the sky
looking
there you are
can I get a lock on to like stay please
okay okay
mimic out
no I thought I was dude [ __ ]
now I don't have the health to use a
mimic
what are you gonna do now
I thought I was out of range
[ __ ]
okay
guys
this is not good
if I got hit by that I die if I can't
buy anything right now I die
this is bad
no
his timing is so annoying
he's gonna do a grab
he did not do a grab
keeps spamming it should stagger it
didn't
I'm just wrong today
there we go
for the ice stab
boom
FP
yeet
yeet
eat
eat
excellent
mimic
smack him in the face more
like this
good
Heat
bad time to eat
where are we at where are we at where
are we at
my rock still went right at him dude
oh [ __ ] hell
I didn't think there would be time to
use torrent I was right
uh not gonna be able to reach
I can already tell
what am I doing there you'll never know
it I I did something uh stupid that's
what I did
I did something dumb
so I died
this astral fight is so weird
can we just like given you to sunless
please like [ __ ] hey
calm down dude I took the video down
because nobody liked it
I was like oh okay I guess I'll stick to
Alden ring that's the only reason you
weirdo
parasocial freak
nice
okay
hello
I will tell you I could give less of a
[ __ ] if you unsub
when we're doing a randomizer stream and
you come into clearly start some
unneeded weird drama in your head
and I'm somehow fake for taking down a
video that people gave me feedback on
and said yeah I feel like this is too
negative you should probably take it
down and I'm like you know what you're
right I will
go back to [ __ ] Reddit or something
dude Jesus Christ
maybe like have your own life
tree has let me down several times
wrong thing
okay
up
oh it's a skill issue
hold on
Stan that's a little crazy
it's a little far
I like the way you're thinking though
you are indeed fake just
I don't understand how but okay
you believe whatever you want
and get out of my [ __ ] community
thank you
and I should turn on gamer mode
people like that really grind my gears
dude
they really grind my
my gears
gamer mode Let's Get It
gamer mode engaged
[Music]
thank you
this was done
actually
he's why didn't he jump he just never
jumped
he never jumped
he had no health
I just thought at some point there he
would jump
Andrew thank you again bro you're
amazing
and bizarre welcome good to have you
here man
thank you very much
no the sound like depends on what it is
so if you become a member it's godric
and then Super chats are Reichard
and then if somebody Subs it's Alexander
why would you do this
and
should be good here
we'll take it
okay
not good
not good at all
there you are
wow holy [ __ ]
oh
it didn't work
No more healing
scared
okay
good
oh
thanks for taking the hit there mimic
foreign
[Music]
hit him
no don't work
I really thought that would stagger
yeah
get a mimic
I got it
a little risky
hey run away
nice
foreign
okay
mm-hmm
that's what I thought
bruh
it's work please thank you
running to the side
guys a runarc won't give me more Health
right
no
oh this sometimes this timing is so bad
call people out on their hypocrisy what
are you talking about
did I like you're calling me not genuine
or whatever did I promise anything to
you
what are you talking about I discussed
the state of play I didn't like this day
to play I thought it was unnecessary
all the things in that were like okay
but they all could have been their own
trailer
then they showed a God of War thing that
everyone was hyped up about
it wasn't that big of a deal
and people were like man I feel like
you're really negative about this and I
thought they were right so I took it
down
that's it
I still didn't like it but that doesn't
mean I have to put anything out there
that's negative
fine
so I don't know what you're saying
what part is ungenuine
you're just being an [ __ ] to be an
[ __ ] at this point
how is that what are you talking about
you don't understand what those words
are saying me
I can change my mind about things
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
and you're saying it's like eldering DLC
you mean the DLC that hasn't been
announced yet
we got this game for 60 dollars
that's given us six seven months of
content
no
paying more for extra content puts a
sour taste in my mouth what was that in
regards to
so think about what I said before you're
just like
it's so genuine like you're saying
what was I talking about
because I think the only thing you have
in your head right now is well that's
just like Elder and DLC when it's not
welcome scarov
s Legacy right so the game that's
already gonna be seventy dollars ten
more dollars in this game
and then if you want whatever it was
like some
hogsmeade shop right
you have to pay more
that's not even DLC the game hasn't come
out yet bro Elder Ring's been out for
six seven months how is that comparable
it's not
I think you're just trolling I can't
tell at this point
if you are dude
cut it out
dude you have no idea what you're
talking about holy [ __ ]
that's not how DLC works
the hogsmeade thing is DLC for a game
that does it's not even out yet it's not
out till February
like come on man
I'm tired of these people that just like
comment on [ __ ] that they do clearly
don't understand
yeah what is it pre-lc
my goodness
we probably should disband them
throwing off the vine
no kidding
yeah I deserve that
oh did you ban him or tying them out oh
you timed him out Andrew thank you man I
I we probably should just ban them like
who comes into a stream that's about a
randomizer and just starts talking about
random [ __ ]
I almost put a video cost to edit
oh I don't know
I edit my own videos
this isn't full random what are you
talking about
is everyone okay today man I just wanted
to play randomizer
is this a randomized chat room right now
like what's going on dude
okay band thank you
and then he's like I think we got off on
the wrong foot no [ __ ] dude you came in
here hostile what the [ __ ]
oh you're asking giz okay cool
give me some context every item I pick
up every boss
uh and and rewards we get from bosses
are randomized
he's salty you stream for work yeah it's
fun I worked my ass off to get to this
point man
I'm happy but I understand that like
with some sort of success there's just
gonna be people who like
get so mad about it for some reason
but whatever
okay I'm gonna Focus now I'm I am over
it let's go I want to beat this thing
we're already an hour in and we're still
here
okay Melania just ban Melania as well
clearly a part of it
or someone named Melania
radon
we're done
you good bro
he's stuck
okay I always forget
[Music]
bad millennia
I hear you there you are
foreign
my God the damage
yes
okay come on let's go
please give me time to do this
thank you
to be okay
okay
he usually does two of these yep
could be good now
Bonk perfect
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
okay
yeah we gotta take our time here that's
true we really do
I kind of want to use something besides
Rock sling Maybe
[Music]
Pro Gamer
because this takes a little bit too long
Pro Gamer by the way
I knew it
I'm so smart come here
I pre-ran it
one of these
we got one of these
same spot
tried to grab her mimic
dumb as hell
where'd he go okay
[Music]
Pro Gamer
I'm gonna say that every time
it's to inflate my ego
one more time
okay
nice
he's gonna do one more
dodging couldn't be better
uh don't have FP that's bad
Pro Gamer
oh [ __ ]
we got lucky straight up luck
had nothing about being a Pro Gamer
that should stagger
never mind
not when it does nothing
[Music]
yep we got the shards
there it is get a mimic
destroy
excellent excellent
get it delete it
that's fine I don't give a [ __ ] about
that attack it's a bad attack
Pro Gamer
dodging is very on point right now
where you at you know [ __ ] that's where
you're at
that won't hit me
I don't even know where that went
um come on hit him hit him
oh piss out my ass
you [ __ ]
mimic think thank you for being here I
need you over there I ain't gonna cap
bro
I accidentally used my FP bar
I really did do that
excellent
mimic is dead
that was a good hit I like that
I don't know what he's doing right now
though
we gotta fight him straight up now boys
actually
guys that doesn't do what we thought it
did
that does not do what we wanted
that does not do what we thought it did
The Starlight Shard does not do what we
thought
foreign
ER
[Laughter]
okay okay
I don't think Rock sling is our play
we'll see what else we got
I I don't think it's I don't think it's
the play it's just too weird
oh we can't use lightning
here's the other thing I could try and
fight him like at like straight up
now I don't have flame of the red Mains
that's the hard part about this is like
we don't know where anything is so we
can't just like go get it
well I'm using Rock sling not for damage
but to stagger him it's really good for
that so's flame of the red Mains by the
way we just don't know where it is
we could run around all day and never
find it
could we use B steel sling isn't this a
bit faster or the stone agarank
we could try this or I just fight him
straight up and just dodge his attacks
let's try we gotta try something else
I think I think we're good we can do it
the way we are I just need to be a Pro
Gamer you know what I mean
like if I don't become a pro gamer right
now guys I'm just ungenuine and fake
foreign
okay I'm over it I'm over it laugh it
off I'm moving on now
all right you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh that attack gets me pretty much every
time
come on
we have not fought malacath yet now
you'd stand doing some moderating today
old hits
okay go go go go
he did
okay we starting off strong I see
get that out
swing it out
he's already spamming not a good sign
oh I have the wrong thing equipped for
the stone
come on fast fast okay
let's see this speed
[Music]
okay I completely missed that doesn't
help either
they hit him right in the Noggin
oh
he is not getting knocked however
together
I thought he might grab me
use rivers of blood
I don't like the rock guys
Dwayne The Rock Johnson not being
helpful
we just took the hit there honestly
that's way too far away for me to care
excellent
and back down Andrew thank you
try to grab me
[ __ ] you thought
I think this might be the play
maybe not
can you can you stop that
let's use this
we're just going all out now
mimic's dead
what is he doing he's just going crazy
I'm real Brave right now I ain't gonna
cap
that just insta kills me
I didn't think it would kill me bro I
think I should just I think I should
just fight him straight up
I I think that's the play hello hello
Andrew thanks again
I think straight up and we can do it
what dies every time I spawn
we got this
wait wait
one more Health thing
okay this is where I go full gamer mode
don't change anything about my build
don't listen to anything chat tells me
to do and just bang my head against the
wall until I beat the boss
foreign
if you've been in this stream that's
that's usually how this goes
I have radon's great Rune and I'm
fighting against radon isn't that
hilarious
so just get worse I mean yeah probably
I mean are you really here for me to
just succeed at everything
come on
exactly
exactly pack I just got to put my nuts
in his face
we can't use Scarlet Rod I don't have
the the attributes for that the levels
allocated
mm-hmm
excellent excellent
let's just take our time and get good
right I mean I think that's it
son of a [ __ ]
you dead
that doesn't work I literally can't get
that off in time
that's fine I like it when he does that
above me
cool
all right let's go
it's focused over there
get down
awesome Bonk
dude he kind of going Breezy right now
see if that does anything it's it's
doing stuff
we are certainly doing things there
yes oh God
come on bro
you think this will reach somehow
nope
dude get down here bro nice
come on like how how are you not
like something
okay I didn't die but my mimic did
a lot of damage there bro
no no
not like this
we'll take it
we will take that
I have never dodged that so close
can't roll fast enough to dodge the last
one
get down here
get down here
holy [ __ ]
it's fine we'll take the one hit we
gotta play real passive now bro
extreme passiveness
not going for a grab
Pro Gamer
he
like he just starts spamming it's so
annoying [ __ ]
he just did two swipes
damn it
yeah I didn't want to just run away
that's clearly what we should be doing
though
just fighting him straight up I didn't
even Dodge everything quite right
we got it let me use this right away
because I think it just lasts forever
any grilled cheese
thank you Andrew
grilled cheese grilled cheese
thank you
full
I always forget to lock onto radon for
some reason
you don't
come on baby
I want it now
I don't know where he is
hello
foreign
okay
dude just calm down for like a second
there we go thank you
I'm not a Pro Gamer
one more
go
Pro Gamer we're back
that won't reach
you're bad
that won't reach either you're bad
it's hitting him it's hitting him
I don't know if he's glitching or
something but I like this
run run quickly
get back in there never mind run away
and grab
you got my mimic that's okay
you should go right back here
Pro Gamer we are really out here right
now
come on stagger you [ __ ]
foreign
yes this is it
hit him with the big
passiveness
back to passive
major passive
mimic get in there
that's fine we like that attack
we don't like this one though
okay we do
one more one more don't kill me yes
let's go
let's freaking go
easy first try
first try
I think the mimic got the kill
legit
GG zero deaths
absolutely no problem at all
I feel like we need more decks
I will do mine
Pro Gamer Jake I knew it angel thank you
for I don't know what that currency is
but it looks like it's one dollar I
appreciate it thank you very much
I got a somber smithing Stone Bell three
there's yes smithing Stone Bell bearing
three
which gives us random [ __ ] anyway
I almost fell
we will devour the very God
all right
let's go bro
Don's moon is still there that's kind of
cool
okay wait before I go we gotta discuss
this
what ending do you guys want
I think I have the key to finish
Ronnie's ending
actually
dude ninja subscribed cool
death
thank you for becoming a tarnish welcome
good to have you here I appreciate you
enjoy the emotes
we're getting a lot of members today
guys I appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you all right we'll do a
poll I'll do a poll because I can't you
guys are saying everything we can do the
dung eater ending
I'm pretty sure we can do the Ronnie
ending if I like go finish it which we
can
we'll do a poll
okay so dung eater
Ronnie
lame let's just do those three
Frenzy
FTW okay I know what Andrew's vote is
gonna be thank you man for all the super
chats too you're nuts you guys are crazy
today thank you
okay ask your community
boom
you should be able to vote
I'll do whatever this vote says
blame a frenzy's winning so far
yeah I appreciate it Andrew thank you
burn away the storm Birds yeah [ __ ]
those birds
exactly exactly
it's pretty close between the okay now
dung eater took the lead I'll let this
go for a little bit
because
I would have to if we want to do flame
of frenzy I'd have to go do that now
right
it's literally tied
actually tied right now
and Flame of frenzy takes the lead again
frenzy flame ending ggs thank you blue
eyed how are you man appreciate the five
dollars
thank you thank you thank you
make sure you're voting guys
we're 60 votes in it's really close
between flame of frenzy and dung eater
but it looks like flame of frenzy is
gonna win
burn away the rivers of blood
do an RNG wheel this is close enough to
do that
it's it's winning by a good amount now
it's 44 of the vote
so I think we got to do chaos
yeah if it was closer I would do a wheel
but we'll do this we'll do flame of
frenzy
I've never done the dung eater ending
um it's pretty much like the normal one
except there's poop everywhere
pretty much poop so we have to go do
that now right
before I do this pretty sure I do
I've never done it in any other order
actually
oh God we have to go through the sewers
well we'll just go to it now regardless
that's fine
we love poop
I love poop
poop poop poop
okay I see your message straight I
didn't know there were multiple Innings
three plus days of gameplay and still
don't know anything have you even beaten
the game yet
and thank you for the six months I think
that'll come up pretty soon
you can't get Melina to chase you if she
dies right
I don't know
have you guys ever done it in the order
of like using melano to light the flame
of frenzy
and then couldn't you technically
still go down in the sewers
but she still dies
so does it just change the ending
I've never done it in that that way
[Music]
he just doesn't chase you
or does she I have no idea
you talking about the Melina cutscene at
the end like when she is the glow my
queen
she just doesn't
I just don't remember that's a it's been
months of this
if you do flame a frenzy before you go
to pherom melanin will leave you
and you light the tree I know that
what I'm saying is let's say we light
Melina
and then from Farrah Missoula we just
randomly go to
the
the sewers become the flame of frenzy
and then do that ending
is the only difference that the glomide
queen ending doesn't show up
that's what I'm trying to say
okay gotcha that makes sense
Molina does not appear as Jack if she
sacrificed
that makes sense okay thank you angel
thank you everybody okay
um well I want her to chase me I love
being chased it's kind of like one of my
things it's like one of my Kinks so
let's do it
the more you know about me right I mean
[ __ ]
whoop
whoop whoop okay if I remember right we
went over in this corner and it was
ridiculous
yep burn
we are so much stronger now
get out of my way
peasants
spit
hey yo what up bro
okay
I fell I'm lost now
we lost bro
I hear something menacing
seven
ew there's a bird over there bro
okay
yes we killed Melania
like hello why is there a dragon here
bro
like what
like there's actually a dragon
the sewers is crazy guys holy [ __ ]
calm down mate calm down calm down
that was a good attack
hey yo what up
I think I staggered him
yep
okay
he's dead
we are good
we are so ridiculously strong now
oh hold on
whoa
okay
I don't know how we're getting out of
this but here we are
um where do I go
it's so hard to tell like how much is in
here you know
Wolfie stay right there okay
thank you never mind [ __ ] you
excellent
is that a bear
um he said is sticking straight down
he was like stuck dude okay we jump over
that wow three Trina's lilies
excellent
okay I don't know where I'm going
that was clip Worthy
through
okay
who flushed a bear dude right
probably going a little above what I
need to do
yeah I have a plus 10 weapon there's no
way we would get through here otherwise
thank you
it was Trina and why does she have
lilies it's uh
Saint Trina is mikola that's pretty much
confirmed at this point right
we got another bird
[ __ ] you bird
okay what's this Starlight Shard kind of
worthless
foreign
how do you know that it says in some
item description
and then
um wasn't it Lance at Lance McDonald
figured it out
forget exactly who
it's Michela and Drax
Nicholas a three wolf person
you mean in Fair Missoula
I'm pretty sure that's Melina or the
glomide queen
that would make the most sense to me
and almost killed me dude
stop it with your poopy farts
foreign
it's Rick we're dead
I possibly defeat Rick
we got lucky
yeah three wolves person I'm pretty sure
is the glomide queen which would be
Melina
what up pale blood
in the flame frenzied flame is supposed
to drive you insane that's why shippery
grows Birds down here
right imagine imagine having any other
reason
oh God
I Think We're Dead Boys
great glove board though
these guys got hella Health dude
that's what we're talking about
the three wolves person in pharah
Missoula the statue behind uh malacath
pretty sure he's a glow my queen
oh God
the snail sees me
okay that's our way down
I want this item I might die in the
process of getting it
I should have grabbed this first
what makes you say that so
I mean we've discussed who we think
Melina is right
how she's like a manifestation of
the glomide queen and
from Saint
from Queen America right
that's what I believe to be true
oh it's a little snake
I thought you'd fall I really did
we're gonna go this way hold on I need a
place to like think
this is gonna be ridiculous
I think I'm dead
yeah
just keep going
just keep swimming
how am I alive
how how
we gotta be close to [ __ ] something
that's going to give me health love it
yes
no he went right through that
statue of the same person is in the
halig tree and why will Halo tree have
Melina statue it's not the same statue
oh we didn't okay so we opened
what we opened that over there so now we
can just run straight through this this
is fine
well his needle works in the Placid do
sacks Arena
not exactly pharah Missoula
but that whole area is about destined
death which has everything to do with
the glomite queen
and Melina
okay we are way better off than we were
before
foreign
it's not the same person from what I
remember it's the same person I don't
what
I don't understand that sentence
uh
I'm gonna kill this guy
what skip are you guys talking about hey
satrina's torch
Oh you mean jumping into the thing I
know what you're talking about now
isn't that over here
that's where I'm trying to get to oh God
it's not the same but the statue from
what I remember is the same person
okay
I'm not sure
I don't know what this guy's doing
I have to go
these things are throwing me off I have
to get over there
I remember us looking in a lore hunting
stream for those statues and they were
not the same
we wanted them to like we thought they
were the same but they're not
I think one is of Michela in the Haley
tree with Melania right
hello wolf
nope that's where we want to be right
here we
where are you running
why are you running
why are you running
my man's just kept running
[ __ ] you man
how did I skip the skip
what are you talking about
I jumped over
it's not a thing
clearly don't know what you guys are
talking about unfortunately
we have to go down here
no
I get so lost
okay that's where I jumped into
okay that guy's glitching a bit
[Music]
and you guys might no more nighty with
this
foreign
that's not where we want to be
give us when you jump
from the stairs above the little cage
elevator
you said little cage elevator
oh is it not like an in-game shortcut
it's just like a thing somebody found
where I fought the snake
really
wow
well
I'm sure I'll get lost and frustrated
enough to do it
right now I'm just kind of running
around
there are multiple tutorials on YouTube
you guys think I watch YouTube bro
I do sometimes
not reliable but fun okay
so it's a straight up glitch gotcha I
don't want to do that
that's
okay well we're finding things we
haven't seen yet that's gotta help a bit
we continue to go down
got skin Apostle trousers excellent
I love that I love that for us
okay
no I have not found a lantern I would
wish I had
let me check maybe we got it like
randomly
no Lantern we have Nicholas needle
though
which we really don't need
I am lost as [ __ ] right now
dude is that the entrance
oh yeah Trina's torch
oh we have many torches
let's make it purple because I like I
like the color purple
this is nice
do I need to go down there let's [ __ ]
try it
my heart
oh God please no I've been here for so
long
[Music]
what
what
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
get me out I want to go back for that
item however we are just right next to a
thingy
okay
we will come back however
because there was a cool item there
but at least we got the grace
Jesus
yeah we don't know who this is gonna be
yeah I did it without a guide
I played the entire uh my first
playthrough without looking up anything
I didn't I did not look at YouTube for
like a month
however I never found placidusacks and I
never found Millennia because of that
though in my first playthrough I had to
look it up in the second
hey yo what up bro
hey yo that's cool
we are gonna move we are gonna move
uh it might last that long Andrew not no
cap
like actually mine
okay you
stop being mean
really
it's a large room boys we found it
that's fine
I have a big heart so I accept that
we're looking more closely they aren't
the same but three-year-old person is
still make love for me it very well
could be
that we just have two different theories
mug that's totally fine
there's nothing wrong with that I I
thought it was Michela 2 for the longest
time I it very well could be but I think
it makes more sense to me that it's the
glomide coin
we can do a lore hunting stream and talk
more about it but having a different
opinion is totally fine
don't don't even stress it
probably shouldn't use that huh
I think uh the souls Community kind of
needs to
stop hating people for having different
opinions on what they think the game is
about
not hating but just like totally
dismissing other people's theories it's
really weird
oh no
no vati's not overrated are you kidding
me he's making the best Elder ring
content a hundred percent
this is gonna suck
yep time to switch endings
wait why don't you guys like vati what
I love vati's videos they're so good
he's basically did you guys not see his
trailer for his next video coming out he
had a trailer on his second channel for
what he's doing and it was my exact idea
for a movie it's like [ __ ] I'm not gonna
be able to compete with that
yeah Smoketown and vati I think are the
two best Elden ring content creators
thank you Andrew
good luck hahaha
I do have the Blasphemous claw though
that'll help a bit right
I mean as an option
so do I just use it and it'll just
deflect it
but can I use it now
oh I have to literally Parry
morgot was a godskin noble it wasn't
that cool
I like vati at least one of the best
does not like to try to force you adhere
to ethereum and also is really chilling
when mistakes are made
yeah I I love it man
I think he like he has an entire team
behind him as well
which you know he's got how many Subs
does spotty have like two million almost
three million
I I'm actually stalling from this fight
right now by the way I'll totally admit
that I'm stalling
you can also Parry the moves when he's
in the air
can I Parry any attack or is it just the
black flame attacks
yeah his his frenzied Flame video was so
incredibly good
that's that's probably the best video
he's ever put on his channel
body's great I found your vids because I
watched his
well yeah a lot of our communities
intertwine for sure I watched his backs
and theories go hand in hand and now we
discover new things that's like so I
would compare
I would compare smoke town and vati
right I think they go hand in hand
showing a lot of facts and now vati's
getting more cinematic with everything
which is super sick and it makes the
videos just that much better right
I don't feel like I'm really like
anybody one because I interact with my
community I think more than anybody else
where I stream all the time and talk to
you guys
which I don't see on YouTube much at all
except for other streamers on here right
uh and then I make like really far out
there theories like they don't have to
be like a hundred percent factual it's
just like putting it out there you know
what I'm saying
like coming up with things for people to
discuss
and it's not like I'm just throwing out
like any you know like malacheth as
mikola or something [ __ ] dumb like
that
but just going over what I think and
like deeper meanings of things
instead of like presenting all the facts
which is just as important
yeah kind of like saying the Cocoon man
isn't mikola which I still think
is true
but I'm not I'm not going to discuss
that again people hated that theory bro
they hated it
honestly the only two Elden ring other
content creators that watch is Smoketown
and bhati so
[Music]
like you can believe you can believe my
theory or not that's fine but
I can't wait for DLC like can you
imagine that we learned that the guy in
the Cocoon isn't mikola
you know I'm gonna get on stream and
I'll be like I [ __ ] told you guys
but that's fine and then if I'm wrong
I'll be I'll admit it I'll be like you
know what I was wrong you right my bad
are all of his attacks just gonna get
Bodied
okay I got it
I tried to get behind him
this is gonna suck
yeah I've heard the theory that our
character is Michela as well
I don't know about that one I like it
though
yeah that wasn't bad
you can only Parry when a sword is gold
here's an audio cue
okay I I don't know if I want to try
that man
yep might as well just ship my head to
the wall I'm banging it against the wall
here
you've never been able to pair him
it looks like it's gonna be extremely
hard that's for sure
I am not gonna try
looks like that might be a consistent
thing that happens
what hit me hello
foreign
dog sit still
owie
no clue how I'm alive right now
I what
what
why
okay
I turned into a literal Legend for a
second and then through
all good to hear Tommy I'm glad you like
them man
yeah I should use a mimic too I didn't
even think of that
I did not think of a mimic I think I
could beat him without it this does this
actually doesn't seem that bad
because technically malachath does not
have that giant of a health bar
no no we're fine
we are good
yeah he always hits the wall right there
that's lucky
I did a quarter of his health right
there
see his his sword is kind of gold right
there
weird
oh this time that
I don't know how to get behind them in
that situation
manic's dead
I somehow dodged that
foreign
bam
okay we can kill him
saw you presenting the godskin duo song
lyrics and even though they're not
exactly accurate it's still very
entertaining mizaki had more songs
composed to enrich the story I'd love it
I'd love it too it turns out that that's
not true
and that the what's his name again
Daniel something
he thinks he's doing it but he's not
unfortunately I find it really
entertaining too but
can't just go like
you know what I mean
I wish it were true I need to take off
the torch
for our mimic
what is he doing
[ __ ]
but I got so distracted by my mimic
my son also sits here with me when he
hears your videos he has a preference
now at one year old
I got a one-year-old watching my videos
I love that thanks man
my voice must be very relaxing
even though I don't think that about
myself at all
okay let's get rock sling back in no
maybe not rock sling
I don't know I'm just gonna get my mimic
an option
yeah I cuss a lot so
I don't know if that's good for a
one-year-old
yeah the mimic looked really cool
this is gonna be too slow but I'm giving
my mimic an option like maybe he'll have
time to eat it or something I don't know
is malacath America's brother or Shadow
uh both
Shadow means brother it's like uh
well Shadow means shadow
it's both
all right malacheth
okay that doesn't damage me
almost time that right
God gamer
not so much
yes rocksling
don't kill me
he's so close
thank you
we clutched up boys
Fiji
freaking easy
gravity Stone Peddler's Bell bearing
and a hundred thousand runes
big
we do so much damage unbelievable
what would you say is the most
entertaining build
what does Melina say right here
I don't know I like a lot of builds in
this game I find a lot of builds to be
extremely fun claim the frenzied Flame I
ask
Ed it is not to be meddled with it is
chaos devouring life and thought
unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair
life endures
births continue There is Beauty in that
is there not if you would become Lord
do not deny this notion please
I love the frenzied flame alone
just out and hello
way to ruin the moment thanks for the
subs though welcome
[Laughter]
all right let's get it boys
wow a dragonfly head
what does that look like
oh that's actually not a head okay sick
you guys like the way I look let's get
some good lighting here
oh yeah you ready for this
beautiful
a true Lord
even better
we hide most of his face
are we not going to get a violin
no violin
no he got replaced
it's jump in time
it is Jump In Time thank you Arc
I appreciate the uh two Euros man thank
you
I think Melina's purpose just can't be
to return deaths and death to the world
because she actually sacrifices herself
before defeating before beating
malachyth instead she would make sure we
defeat malachith first
well I think she trusts us enough to do
it at that point right
where we don't do this are you kidding
this is already hard
okay I'm staying here for a second
what the [ __ ]
oh boys
this was already hard enough
okay that's helpful
okay I just got annihilated by this
thing
give me back my violin guy
all right
place your bets how many times am I
gonna die attempting this [ __ ]
platforming section
oh
okay
okay turn on the god gamer turn it on
[Laughter]
turn it on baby
God gamer is going pretty good
[ __ ] you
poopy
okay so it's not a roll there
now
I took a risk
we had to get out of there quick
oh
my character didn't roll
my character just said no I'm not gonna
do it
[ __ ]
yeah imagine if we still had old
controls for jumping
I I literally can't imagine
[Music]
why am I so like what
I'm going too fast
because I'm getting shot by arrows
dude what are we at three deaths
all right time to turn it on
turn this whole thing on its head bro
let's go
[Music]
God you know they were laughing their
ass off
in the studio when they made this
[ __ ] platforming section bro
like you know they're laughing at us
[Music]
I'm so scared
I think I can roll right there right
my character did the same thing
same exact [ __ ] thing
just nothing
no role at all
if you listen close enough you can hear
Miyazaki crying from laughter
I'm
upset about that
I'm mad about what just happened
they'll be platforming with a poisonous
swamp
imagine they make a platforming section
with all of the birds in the game
and then you get to the bottom and it's
all dogs
okay
no this is where I've been
let's chill
it's right here I don't know this is
Chill too
I'll jump
excellent
oh [ __ ] this is a roll
okay we're pretty much there
is this a roll or a jump
[Music]
it looks like a roll
guys this is like I would Sprint jump
right over this thing
just walk it my game froze okay there we
go
okay it wasn't either it's just a walk
ooh a great bow augers
okay we pretty much made it
I bet eight not gonna help you
you guys know the the twitch thing where
you can um BET channel points
I wish YouTube had that that's actually
really fun
my game is freezing
it's gonna get me killed
okay
let's go
excellent
why is my game freezing
stop it
okay
we know what Melanie says here she hates
us
so
I think all I have to do is take my
clothes off right
God my body is just insanely attractive
have a good one mug
how does hiata get here before you break
the ceiling
uh she followed the eyes
the shibiri grapes
you guys think the three fingers
touching me is consensual that's a good
point stuff
I think it is
like I walk right in there
see
I'm clearly cool with it
is my character this kinky
like this is Way Beyond like some candle
wax [ __ ]
damn
chat horny yet
damn
I love that there's an after effect
where your eyes glow and your body is
like [ __ ] burned
that's so cool
okay I don't remember what I was wearing
did I change my clothes or do I have to
use the same
outfit I've been wearing the entire time
Briar armor
it's kind of cool
Highway Man what soldier Grieves oh [ __ ]
yeah dude
I think we gotta keep the Hat
we have to
I can't see my eyes though
oh [ __ ]
you
have inherited the frenzied flame uh
you are no longer fit our journey
together
ends here and remember
should you rise as the Lord of Chaos
I will kill you
as sure as night follows day God damn it
which is my duty
for allowing you the strength of runes
goodbye my companion goodbye torrent
why does she let us keep tauren
I just kind of wonder that
have we fought yeah we fought I I can't
believe I just asked have we fought in
mode yet like yeah we have
yeah she's not happy with those guys
oh I didn't like this okay we gotta go
up there
for it shows us
yeah it seems like he didn't choose
quite right
I love the idea of melon killing us I
love it
or it secretly supports the frenzied
flame it's like a childhood friend
turned Republican she has to let him go
no I I think torrent supports us
which in turn
with this ending would be the frenzied
Flame
you missed a chest and a wall down there
that's okay
all right let's burn this [ __ ] down
I'd want Melina to kill me
right
listen to the sounds of flame
foreign
I've been streaming for two hours
already
I hear somebody screaming in that don't
you
I hear lots of things screaming
okay guys
okay now Chad's really horny and now
they're getting political we need to we
need to cut that
right now
burn
it all down
yes
see I when I did this I thought the game
would end right here
and we wouldn't even do the rest
what an interesting life we live Solaris
what an interesting life
one is political one is horny
dude this helmet is actually like really
cool
did you notice that some sites of Grace
you can hear glass bits shattering
um like when it's glowing I think right
we're not glowing the
isn't it like before you light it
it makes that sound
all right
faram Azula time
we'll have to go see who placidusax is
obviously and then Malachi
foreign
okay
oh God
literally anything but that thing
they're right over there brother
go go go go go go
I'm just taking the hits I'm taking it
bro
oh [ __ ]
come on
we already did
we good
I'll have to look out for that ghastly
that seems cool
you should take bets on who they are
that's why I was saying like it'd be
cool to have that twitch feature
you know what I'm saying
where you could bet like if however much
you watch you earn Channel points
I'm saying
is this the Dragon
yep and then you can bet those points
double slash
that's some sekiro [ __ ]
have a good one Chaka Rob
foreign
vest
you want me to put on the gold Mass rags
why do you want me to be pretty much
nakey
I shouldn't even ask that I know why
all right Lord
oh boy
this is not what I wanted
oh God we need to we need to figure out
what God skin Duo is going to be first
why there we go
yeah some enemies are not randomized
he says with a bearer running around
here
Everything is randomized Everything
now that does mean that sometimes
a character that is usually in that area
will still be there just luck at the
draw
two storm Hawk Birds
Sage Rogue oh God
what the [ __ ]
man got up in his hind legs and never
got down
well there's an item
you imagine if Grace was randomized
Godfrey
interesting
how does that hit me bro
oh
looks like just phase one
what
foreign
foreign
foreign
I find God like I've practiced God free
so much I didn't even fight that well
there but I have practiced him so much
that I just love fighting him
I think Godfrey's one of the best fights
in the game like just if you learn the
moveset he is so fair even though first
time I fought him I died so many [ __ ]
times
I just I love fighting him now
but I had to use a mimic and a lot of
heels I could have been way better
all right
now to placidusacks I say
oh boy
yeah horalu is I think a good second
phase but the Godfrey at the beginning
is so much fun
why do you want me to wear God skin Rags
or gold mask rags
no
might as well be naked
missionary's cookbook
Bang
yeah best song and dance that's a good
way to put it
wear the rags
fine
heck are you doing here
get out of my town
hi Esther
hope school's going good
who do we have left who who have we not
fought
foreign
I don't think Rick's gonna be any of the
main bosses unfortunately
somebody explained that in chat the
other day that the randomizer doesn't
work that way
like if it's a main boss area it's gonna
be a main boss
I think we still have to fight like
malakith first phase
eldenbeast
we fought radagon
already
we fought both variants of the fire
giant so it can't be the fire Giant
I hate fighting these things
I I'm not going to what's up here
yeah uh did we fight more God anywhere
I think I'm dead yep
dude those hands are so dumb
yeah we gotta fight Gideon
didn't we fight Malachi somewhere like
his first phase
we gotta fight Hora Lou
yeah we thought more got
um I guess Margot somewhere
the final boss was a turtle
I mean we can up this randomizer to be
even crazier than it is
we'll come up with something
Frank was second phase of Ronaldo that's
right so we already did fight him
oh why are they all the way up there
[ __ ] you
We're not gonna fight Muriel
non-neigh Hill Moog
oh that's right the one
yeah the other Moog
another hand
yeah it didn't see me somehow
the Elden dog
is tree Sentinel a main boss
we fought both variants of Reichard
hey you know what
we'll see
we'll find out
why did I do that
yeah I wouldn't say it was a main boss
either
so close to leveling
as well
Lino misbegotten
is he a main boss too I think so
should be
dragon lord Gideon the all spamming
that's pretty much what he is now
let's go find out who placed to do sex
is
dragon lord Gideon
wait who was the tree Sentinel did we
even kill we haven't even been back to
that side of Grace in so long
yeah we just fought Godfrey
he was the godskin duo replacement
we beat him in one try
it was first phase I have a feeling this
is this right here is gonna be horalu
I was eating cereal it didn't last long
I'll tell you that right now
that's my final answer I think this is
going to be horror Loop
okay we've all seen this
it's not spawned yet
What's it gonna be
Dragon Lord
oh what the [ __ ]
weird
kind of fitting though somewhat
okay
it's gonna yank it
oh this is that one
I forgot about this one
actually really cool
I want to hit the toe
God he hits hard as [ __ ]
oh come on
what
he hits incredibly hard
toes
I'm dead
rip
I'm somehow alive oh my God I dodged it
let's go
first try two glove War Pickers
belvarian somber miners Bell Baron
nice okay
I say that fight was actually kind of
cool it was a cool setting for that boss
Pro Gamer
we really gaming out right now
it's level it's level ant bucket
might have some more options let's go
find Ali Malak at this
it's your favorite kind of tea
um I'm from the Midwest so sweet tea is
a really big deal here
it's really bad for you though but I I
really like it
where's that boss normally
um in a kind of a hidden area of Knox
Stella I believe
knock Stella or nocron
in the underground area
I like this thing a lot more than that
[ __ ] draconic tree Sentinel that's
here
foreign
big helmet
dildo helmet
it's margit
cool
who's gonna be stage two though
just thought of that
thank you
wow that uh just annihilated me dude
wow
he just whipped that [ __ ] out and hit me
with every bit of it
yeah does the voice suit him kinda
okay Jake what do you have to say now my
kid fell asleep in my lap to the stream
apparently I'm boring
sleep to it
that's how I do it
Godfrey was the godskin duo fight
all right let's try that again because I
was doing so well
foreign
I think this fight works here this is
nice like really cool fight
he does a ton of damage
like malikath damage
oh God
he's gonna get spammy
there he goes
God damn
I haven't had 40 this year seven set
today in
777.
777 quadrillion
777
770 777777.
foreign
thank you Andrew
I'm getting annihilated right now
he does a ton of damage
you know what it is look at what I'm
wearing literally nothing
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven seven seven
you guys are slowly turning into twitch
chat aren't you
it's gonna happen you guys started
becoming members donating super chats
all kinds of stuff spamming sevens
you pretty much twitch
I like it
[Music]
the law of regression exactly
exactly
you always go back to what you once were
isn't that what it is
I [ __ ] up there we go
freaking nuts stage two bro
he's obviously scaled
I like that mimic
's kind of nuts
no stage two
there we go
all right who's it gonna be
still streaming hell yeah dude we're
beating this thing
Market did a ton of damage
all right let's see
[Music]
interesting
oh God
okay
we at least got one down
[Music]
Battle of the frostbite part two
God this music kicks ass
we gotta get rid of it this is good
nice
now he'll become Electric
yep
foreign
oh here come the Bots
great timing
thank you
[ __ ]
let's go dude what's up
get out of here
I have turned it took a couple hour
warm-up but I am a Pro Gamer now
we have one-shotted
the last three bosses
or bosses technically or actually never
mind I died to Market a bunch of times I
don't know what I'm talking about I'm an
idiot it felt like one try
I didn't die that many times where'd the
Bots go
I don't see him anymore
whatever they'll come back
we are getting good
we have yet to see Gideon
between Australia
dark fate
at the flames
will also burn the impenetrable thorns
sir Elder divis farewell
we haven't seen the eldenbeast either
you'll be Elden Lord yet it'll be so
lame if the Eldon Beast turns out to be
the eldenbeast
actually I just thought of this I don't
think we can
we can't finish the game until we get
every great Rune I'm pretty sure is a
setting I turned on for this randomizer
yeah we gotta go to the halog tree as
well
let's go see who this is and then we'll
go to the Halo tree
but I'm pretty sure they only drop in
like
uh important areas
yeah we fought via's champions
five
more mine
let's go see who this is
we have not seen who Fortis axes either
we can go do that as well
wait can we even do that at this point
like now that we burned the Earth tree
down
forgot about that
I can do it whenever
it will she just sit there
I look amazing
she's just chilling all right but
we were there days ago
okay that's sick
I don't know why I like that so much
look how cool he looks
whoa
this is gonna be a really weird arena
for him
uh
uh okay let's go
is he not gonna attack
State of Affairs this is cool
this is weird
onto eternity you didn't give a [ __ ]
there we go
rocksling
are we
ow
e
right through him excellent
foreign
I think it's just the ancestor spirit
I got ballistables
not even you it's so funny to see them
say other things
gunnel
a man cannot and he's dead
[Laughter]
ancestor Spirit the all-knowing Imagine
get more mind
our build is very interesting
what's over here
I have very very rarely ever come over
here oh this is like the original that's
right original entrance
a man
cannot become
your mom
yeah I'm just gonna continue
we are really farming these last guys
though
[Music]
do you guys you like my voice acting
there
I think I could pretty much be Gideon
oh man
[Music]
your mom
all right let's go
if it'll even let us in here
can we see
can't see
it's what two ancestor Spirits in a row
what the hell that's so weird
what are the odds
but this one will be the Regal one
foreign
ER
I love the sound it makes
Loki these ancestor Spirits are some of
my favorite bosses in the game
it's really well done
this is so cool
he's not healing
okay
stage two
who we got
oh [ __ ]
the Eldon Beast eldenbeast Warrior
this is gonna be cancer
oh my God this is going to be cancer
rip the mimic
you can't get away from me now
your arena is not big enough
it's still running away though
I have no idea what's going on
how to strength
Jesus Christ
two hits
I I die in two hits man
I'm taking this [ __ ] off by the way this
armor sucks
I like this one
uh the mod has options to make kale sell
you a map of where the great rooms are
okay if we need it we'll do it
all right
let's get it
thank you
Frank
excellent
one more
Bonk
all right let's go
let's go Eldon Warrior whatever the [ __ ]
your name is
what the [ __ ]
foreign
come here
keeps running away from me
oh
by the way you can get hit by that
attack isn't that crazy
okay
bye bye mimick you dumbass
and game over boys
he's getting hurt by his own Elven Stars
they got stuck
I went for it [ __ ] it dude
[Music]
no shot
epic gamer mode and activated dude
[ __ ]
foreign
oh it's my armor
let's go baby
another great rune
drink
befit say Crown [ __ ] yeah it does
how many great runes do we have
let's see
we have
radon
great room of The Unborn
godric morgot and Moog we just need
melania's right
well I'm curious what happens when we go
up here
oh we need reichards too true
yeah look it's just Hollow it won't let
us enter yet
this is cool
examine you cannot proceed without more
great runes I lo that's that's really
cool that they added that into the mod
that's awesome okay
so
um what do we have in terms of the Halo
tree I know we can buy one I think I
already did buy it
a key for it
dectus left and right Haley tree right
we're looking for Halo tree left
hey thanks Brent
Dorothy's sheep Doritos chip doritis
chip Doritos chip
uh I have no idea what you mean by that
but uh yes Doritos I like Doritos
but like [ __ ] so I woke up with all did
I miss you missed a lot we have just
been dominating bosses today honestly
yes I was getting demolished by
malachith
when we were doing our speed run
okay so Castle Soul might have it I
think we should check four to sacks as
well so let's let's let's do the whole
fear questline thing
because I believe I already have
the um
what was I gonna say I already have the
like thing you get at the end
which I don't think we need to get yeah
we need to give it to her that's right
I'm just checking these real quick
okay I have a couple more to turn in I
have a lot more to turn in [ __ ]
okay
okay
oh man corn has good stuff
cool
stock
Doritos chip ending hey there's our
Lantern I'm just gonna buy it [ __ ] it
oh
um
hey
all right okay okay
there's our smithing stone that we
wanted
okay
so
yeah let's go to
let's see what fia's doing if she's
still in here
have a great day at work Belford I'll
see you again soon
did the crafting get randomized I don't
think so if he is not here
is she already down below
there she is oh she looks different
no I just want a hug
oh wait I did not mean to say that
I am the guy
yeah I just want a hug
it's it's soldier of godric there he is
he's actually the uh death bread
Prince
waldkin's blessing
yeah I have it
before the time and I must find it
talking Secret
have I not found it
I sure I did yeah there it is Curse Mark
of Death we have it
oh my with this excellent
yeah hug me tighter mommy please
hug me tight
oh
nothing better than a [ __ ] hug boys
and girls
how are you gonna have sex with this
thing
the new life
brandished this day that by becoming
okay
let's go fight whoever Fortis ax is
gonna be
he's just very you know
be as love language is just physical
physical touch
okay so she should be us why is she not
asleep yet hello
go to sleep do I have to get hugged
again
God this animation takes forever
this is goodbye right right right I
choose to die
greater
this is
you only get rid of the blessing as well
my [ __ ] head
s through her
it's the underlying rage that makes your
comments so amazing
what do you guys mean I never get mad
about anything right
I never get upset
okay now she's asleep
right finger butt hole
deathbed dream
we already fought bike already fought
bike yeah
wait doesn't a dragon always replace a
dragon I just thought of that
nope
or a [ __ ] Lou
foreign
go after the other one man
well
rope
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
owned
absolutely annihilated
trolls Roar great that was not worth it
at all
damn we're rolling right now
all right we found horalu
I guess we could get a great Rune from
her now yeah what is this gonna be
it might not be
yeah Cerulean seed Talisman and a
smithing Stone six
excellent
um okay so what if I sleep is D still
gonna come
oh there's another item
yeah that's poker is [ __ ] amazing I
told you guys
somber9 cool
I think D is not around
yeah you won't be
uh where do we go now
what are we missing here
I have the key
or this
yeah we got to go to Castle Soul we
gotta go to Millennia yep
I mean we're missing two great runes
though
where did you flee my sweet teens Oh I
thought I had the key for that I don't
we don't know where the other halog tree
key is however that's the problem
we gotta go to Castle soul
yeah
isn't the key for the manor
uh what do we open in the manor
so when is the fight with gun deer since
this is a randomizer looking forward to
that fight
um I do plan on playing through Dark
Souls 3 if you're yeah I know how
obsessed you are with gun deer
hahaha
might have to do Cades and dungeons I I
don't think so
because
important items are supposed to stay in
important eye areas
we just don't know exactly where
does that make sense
Dark Souls 3 randomizer
that could be fun
did I fight you I mean you're a boss
right technically
yeah you are
gun deer was my first ever
Souls game Boss
ever
took me like 30 40 tries
we're fighting [ __ ] like this
oh yeah there are gonna be two of them
well no that was like the ability of the
other one
so it might not
Maybe
foreign
didn't though
thank you
idiot
couldn't have said anything
can you stay in one place sir
thank you
yes we killed godskin Duo yep yep
missionary cookbook
what is the celian seal breaker what is
that for
is it weird to say my first Souls game
my first Souls boss was Gail Michael was
playing Dark Souls 3 and was like wanna
turn two hours later I got him phase two
place in my heart that's really cool
your uncle seems awesome
I love that
Quest okay so kind of worthless to us
now
Gail is such an incredible Boss by the
way
out there
nope get away from me
get away from me get away from me
we might have to do lusat to just find
these great runes potentially
okay things are dying left and right
right now
you beat Loretta area
uh
by Ronnie yeah yeah
yeah yeah
I think it's only main bosses
so we're gonna stick to that that can be
uh where this boss is in Castle soul
it's very possible
oh and there's usually a death right
Bird here
Cameron why are you spamming
love Gail his music's right style
everywhere second m is probably Melania
or morgot
agreed
agreed
I think this is just the regular one
now we
oh it's glitched I got [ __ ]
this guy hits like a train
yep rain
they're tied by sheer proximity of your
strength
we really are that strong huh
inflate my ego harder people
inflate that [ __ ]
hold on I gotta
answer a message real quick
I'm trying out the Food Service Factor
do any of you guys
use like does anyone use Factor
I've heard it's okay I usually cancel
these after the first time though
I tried freshly I wasn't huge on it
like the food was kind of meh
factors like they send you food
for you to just heat up in the microwave
thank you metal you're amazing thank you
have you done Dark Souls 3 lore videos
no the my channel basically started from
Elden ring
and Dark Souls Lore has been covered by
everybody already so
scheduled for Wednesday September 28th
it's kind of far away it's like a more
than a week away
I thought you love freshly well they
kept increasing their price every week
which annoyed the hell out of me
and then like their food isn't like
very tasty
keep roaring buddy
now
you might need to use a mimic here
yep metal is literally in my favorite
video that I've made
foreign
videos are not my lore videos by the way
okay we got him now
unless we throw right here
there we go
excellent
is that Rick
I don't know my metal lore so I gotta
find it
I probably should upgrade my staff
that's a good idea
I mean I'm not even using it pretty much
we should try out the mausoleum too
what boss is this like random which
boss is this like random which one would
it be if it wasn't random that's a death
riper yeah
that's right Bird
okay
let's knock this guy down
look it
long
Bonk
Bonk
oh somebody got banned why what happened
we never ban people
must have been a bad cat
it should fall
I think
yep there we go
Commander Melania we already fought
Melania
where golden Godfrey is
YouTube blocks my purchase to become a
member
why is that
it's worked for a few people today we've
gotten a
a bunch of members actually
metal babe smooth all right if
you know I trust you
I trust it
okay we still only have these
remembrances
which one was it the Elden remembrance
that I didn't look at what gave us
God damn it I don't remember I'm pretty
sure I thought it was this one and I was
wrong
okay hopefully I got that right
I did not change the title yes I did I
don't know why I just said I didn't I
definitely did
foreign
it wasn't a thousand times
Steve remembrance Yep this was a
different one so this is one-eyed shield
and eternal Darkness
useless
useless trash
okay yeah I was totally trying to lie
when I just stopped myself and admitted
to actually never mind
never mind
do I see an item over here
hello
oh well now I get this huh cool
oh yeah oh no rip
okay
smithing Stone one I need literally one
more
so
all right
what wasn't random
do that
yeah I don't think D will give us
anything cool
uh all right fine I'll I don't remember
what it's called either because I
changed the title so many times okay
it's uh hold on I'm I'm gonna find it
I haven't made that many videos over the
last like month I've been streaming a
lot though
okay it's called Uh
we struggled against the easiest boss in
the game
less Co-op episode one
and the thumbnail is a drawing by metal
it's very cute
they got 11 000 views which actually
isn't that bad
we almost made another episode and I
lost all of my footage
and I got so mad that I didn't do it
again
I didn't get mad I got upset
oh God
yep get that dog out of there
um
I keep forgetting that my armor can be
used to hurt enemies like can I do this
look at that
petition for more vids with metal and
Jake
Hey listen you know the best way to do
that
views
you know how I know my community likes a
video
they watch it
you guys didn't even know it existed
oh no catapult on this guy
nerd
and honestly it's probably YouTube's
fault for that because they didn't
recommend it because it wasn't a lore
video that's not even your guys's fault
by the way
it's YouTube
I blame them not you
what am I gonna get from this painting
boys and darts
yeah that video was [ __ ] hilarious
too
we could try it again metal if you want
enough time has passed to where I'm not
so upset about it
yeah like do you guys even look at your
um subscriber feed
I always just Open YouTube and it gives
me a bunch of recommended videos that I
watch
but I rarely go to my subscriber feed
I'm not even like subscribed to that
many people
I'm ready to lose the footage again and
restart for the fourth time it would
actually be our fourth attempt
ing Stone ancient dragon smithing Stone
that's pretty good
always subscriber feed okay so I guess
it depends on the
I guess it depends on the person
what is this abnormally large hand what
the [ __ ]
bruh
what is this [ __ ]
okay it died
holy [ __ ] dude
wow
what the
what the
[ __ ] it was one of those stupid laser
balls
maybe we should live stream that metal
hmm
it's kind of all I do now is live stream
capucha
ow
put me back in my corner Mommy
burn
I am so scared
foreign
there's the stupid ball
yeah right there
I can't even hit this thing
oh [ __ ]
okay now I think it's just dead
okay
[Music]
yep the first hour would be just us
trying to fix the mod you're right
that's pretty much what the first video
was
man we don't have all our healing and
stuff but whatever
let's get it
Commander leonine Miss begotten
immediate death huh okay
get a mother me
awesome I love that for us okay let's go
back here because now we can get there a
lot easier
leading really just [ __ ] shot me one
shot me dude
actually just bought my soul
a lot of these bosses that we fought
ought kind of fit maybe except for the
eldenbees outside the herd tree that
kind of made no sense and the Boss Arena
was like
not right
at all
I don't think I'm gonna be able to get a
mimic off because Lee and I and Leon
attacks very quickly
let's just fight him
uh yeah Reichard was not right either
that is true
I agree
get over your view [ __ ]
walk into that
yeah
dumb idiot
God I hate your attack patterns
sometimes
foreign
could have definitely died
input reading
input reading
calm down brother
should have died
dude
oh
he is so annoying
just get the mimic off forehead okay yep
my bad sorry
gifting five Subs if the last ball is
the soldier of godric
bet
have a good one gasly
we need two more great runes
yeah I think it is just RNG if he rushes
me right at the start
I noticed that in his normal Boss Arena
how many how many members can you gift
like what are the numbers that it like
the options it gives you
out of curiosity because I have no idea
okay let me get this ready
yes soldier of God Rick
oh [ __ ] ass
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
uh-huh
now what are you gonna do when you can't
spam your attacks huh
we're gonna bully the [ __ ] out of you in
a corner that's right
hmm
owned
bullied
press one in chat if you agree that some
people in the world do need to get
bullied
I think the wrong people get bullied
but there are some douchebags out there
that deserve to get bullied
it's more the people who do the bullying
that should get bullied
it's not giving you the option to gift
the sub
how did Trey do it then
Trey get the subs the other day
there you go
all right what's this gonna be
yeah let's go this is the normal item I
think
now we can go to the Halo tree
Lord Michelob forgive me that's right
that's the same
you can open the chest and Ronaldo's
room that's right let's go there
just to see
it can allow people to find purpose and
make the world better by getting bullied
the golden order principle
did I not
come out say I you know what it is I
think when people re-subscribe I don't
have a an alert for that
so my bad metal thank you for the four
months it says four months of being a
great rune
that's a higher level than a tarnish so
thank you very much I appreciate that
I wonder why you can't gifts members
though if you wanted to it's kind of
weird
we keep a Realty Chief I need to get
bullied when I did
I'd been so annoying if I didn't
exactly
YouTube's whack I think it's uh
I think YouTube streaming is the future
like I think it's gonna overtake twitch
someday
um
it it's not there yet but I think it
will
you literally can't become a member what
happened why not
let me go on my phone
go to Turtle pop
we already did that a few days ago
YouTube's blocking my stuff
is there like a thing you gotta turn on
maybe I don't know
yep I have the membership button
when I go into it
learn more about memberships
no I have the membership button
can I become a tarnished
can I subscribe to my own channel or
become a member to my own channel
let's find out
hold on
gotta test it see if it works
I was running do like a custom build
Elder ring weapon of your choice
whoa Cameron that'd be insane
okay payment successful require author
authentic authentification
for purchases
yes always
okay
it looks like I did it
oh thanks
it says welcome yep there I am
it works
yep very dyslexic clearly
[Music]
there it is
it did not give me the option to gift
though
I didn't see that either but we've
definitely gotten gifted here before
that's weird
I had to test it [ __ ] you
get more items
can I give the golden order principle
you Muriel
I thought I had to give that to our boy
so I'm doing welding right now and I was
wondering would you like a custom build
eleanoring weapon of your choice or
statue of your favorite character
I mean yeah I would [ __ ] love that
dude that sounds awesome
greetings
do you need any
give prayer book golden order principle
what have we here
very well let us Pharisee is not all
things right
you have assassins
does the same thing for every one of
them
study sorcery study incantations
these are kind of lit
okay
that's all we got
I clicked the link to become a member
and Paige isn't found
well I would recommend refreshing the
page if that's the case it clearly works
and maybe there's some like verification
thing you have to do I have no idea
YouTube's very new to memberships in
general
especially gifting sometimes it's there
sometimes it's not it looks like
okay we can go to the Haley tree now so
let's go
a replica of the Blasphemous blade would
be [ __ ] sick
extremely hard though
trying on PC
sure
yeah maybe isn't it like you can't gift
on mobile
right I swear I heard that somewhere
okay
okay
all right
let's get it get it
you know what they really need
is
um you guys know what twitch Prime is
if YouTube had a twitch Prime oh man
where you could become a member for free
once a month to one person
that'd be big
that's a hand isn't it
oh boy
check your Twitter once please I don't
have Twitter
what the f
uck
interesting
interesting
Twitter is cancer
do I tell you guys this or do I not tell
you this
now you're gonna be like what dude
[Music]
hmm
oh God
[ __ ] all that
um I can tell you this I pretty much
with
social media
I deleted my Twitter I deleted my
Instagram I don't follow anybody on tick
I deleted my Tick Tock I didn't delete
the account but I don't have tick tock
on my phone
because I plan to do clips and stuff but
never have it on my phone again
um
I don't have YouTube on my phone
I don't have YouTube Studio on my phone
I can go to like if I want to look at
YouTube and like listen to a podcast or
like resub like I just did
I have to go into the Google account
like the the Google search bar which
makes it harder for me to go into it
so like I pretty much made it like
really hard for me to go on any of these
websites
[Music]
did you get it Brent
let's go
and you're a great Rune thanks man I
appreciate that
thank you bro
thank you thank you the only I guess
form of social media I have is uh it
worked on PC okay
thanks for letting me know it seems like
PC is better
they gotta they gotta make their mobile
better
um I have Discord I don't really go on
it that much though
um I completely deleted Twitter I think
Twitter is like a cesspool of like
people creating unnecessary drama and
just being dicks to be dicks
um and just spouting their opinions
everywhere like it's nothing
uh so I found it just like I don't need
to be on here at all
um
Instagram I never really cared about so
I just got rid of it
I never had fate I haven't had Facebook
since I was a kid
but I don't have
I don't have any of the apps on my phone
like I still like listening to YouTube
videos sometimes
um
so I have to go on like uh just like a
normal search on Google to watch it
and I don't have an app that gives me
like easily accessible and then if like
if you're a Creator on YouTube like you
know what YouTube studio is it gives you
like all your analytics all the time and
you can constantly check and it updates
your comments and everything I
completely got rid of that app I don't
look at my statistics at all anymore
because that was like all I was looking
at for a while
and I just thought it was unhealthy and
it gave me like a bad mentality about
everything
um
so I would say I quit like a bunch of
social media
and all I do is like I love streaming so
I just stream and talk to you guys live
um
I sometimes post to the Community page
but I have to go through like I just
made it harder for myself to like even
look at my Analytics
in comments and stuff I just thought
it'd be better for me like better mental
health-wise
because I think social media is really
[ __ ] bad for you
it can be good
but it's really
if you're if you're on it a lot like I
was it wasn't healthy so I just I just
cut it
and I've been happier ever since
Izzy Cameron that's gonna be sick I love
his music man I play at the beginning of
every stream or the last couple
Instagram's nice for my business but I
never use it personally right so like I
plan on making clips from these streams
and putting them on Tick Tock but I
don't have tick tock on my phone does
that make sense so like I have to go on
my computer and post those clips from my
PC and nobody wants to like watch Tick
Tock from your computer right
it's totally a phone thing
so I just like it's not on my phone
which means I'm not on it that much
you still have the discovery app and
Facebook I don't even know what those
are
use tick tock from your PC I I
personally I never did so now I'm not on
Tick Tock very much it's all like
preference right
or not preference like whatever you like
to watch it on I just don't like to
watch stuff on my computer because I sit
at my computer all the time
like when I'm not streaming or making
videos I am not on my computer
okay
see what Melanie is gonna be
mhm
my brain has been much clearer
because I've only done this for the last
couple weeks like I haven't been doing
it that long where I'm not looking at
social media
um
I would say my mind is a lot clearer and
I'm just like overall a lot
not as stressed out I would say
oh cool helmet is that everything
because these are plentiful
looks like it
no I'm getting lost
where are the lights
shoot
welcome back Toby
my wife is trying to get me to make tick
tocks of my Eldon ring Clips she loves
watching me play I just don't know how I
just don't
I just don't know I guess
I mean
if you're trying to grow a brand tick
tock's really good for that
that's where I I would say I got my
start
I have 200 like 20 230 000 followers on
Tick Tock and I barely ever post on it
now
because I was all from rocket League
I would say followers don't matter much
on uh
tick tock
here we go
welcome back great petite
we should see what this other [ __ ]
boss is to in this cave
it's over here
yep
you just usually shy
I feel you
whatever you're comfortable with you
know
the difference between social media
that's more social and more media I use
Discord to hang with friends but Tick
Tock is like an IV drip for
entertainment and that's not healthy
exactly I agree with that
I followed you Tick Tock you're welcome
thanks man
what up Mabel
it isn't a main boss though but we might
find Rick
imagine
I think the other variant of astel is
still available to us
I can't open this can I
oh God
foreign
I did watch a video that's called uh
what was it called
Tick Tock is ruining Society
I think is what it was called
or Tick Tock is destroying Society
that that video resonated very hard and
made me want to start not being on
social media as much as I was
don't knock me off please
you know what you should make Cameron
Rick's helmet
oh I just wanted to dodge that there we
go
get me out of here
yeah I don't I forget who it's by I
would just look it up and you'll you'll
find it
hello Amber
oh boy
oh come on dude and they do as much
damage
[ __ ] off
Slayer
foreign social media I do is Xbox it's
probably okay
I mean it's definitely okay
if I had a [ __ ] um
is this
if I had a kid they would never be on
social media
ever
no shot
at least not till they're an adult
like if if they were a kid
oh they would never get that
never ever
a beast when they're an adult they can
make their own decisions
until then they're not getting on social
media nowhere
when a weapon with that order of yours
I would just like a helmet that'd be
cool
well this is extremely underwhelming
a beast one
big damage
wow you really stretched that out huh
wow
thank you
that damage is crazy
see ya buddy
hey we got a [ __ ] mushroom three
mushroom and 120 000 runes nice
that was not worth it
social media probably be way worse for
kids
I had this realization uh about a couple
months ago
where
um my my cousin came with her two kids
and her kids are eight and five years
old
those kids were quite literally like
they had no social skills
which I know is like
um we want to go here
they were what I mean by that is that
they were [ __ ] plastered to their
phone and their iPad
they they had
they didn't talk to us at all they would
whisper to their mom
and that was it and then they'd just be
on their iPad and I swear to God these
kids were looking at like
there was no
like they could watch anything on Tick
Tock YouTube they they were like
mindlessly watching it for hours and
hours and hours on end
whatever you want to do Cameron
it's up to you my man I disappreciate
that you're doing it
hello nameless white mask
name is
oh God it's like pretty much Vari
stop it
lights are hard
oh come on bro
bugs last forever
what happened to my [ __ ] huh
there we go
I won't allow my nephew to do that not
on my watch right
aren't we doing the same right now
watching you I'm assuming all of you are
grown adults and you can make your own
decisions and I you're at least talking
in a chat room
like you I'm assuming it doesn't like
consume you and you're not like all over
it all day which if it does that's a
problem that you should work on but I
can't tell I'm just watching these kids
like all day mindlessly watching YouTube
like watching Mr Beast and SS Sniper
Wolf react to like some random [ __ ]
um
when they're five years old you know
what's funny this this was the funniest
thing bro
when
so like they have a timer on how long
they can be on it right their mom said
it on their iPad and their phone
funniest thing
so the timer opens and you have to put
in a code
to go back into it right or else it just
locks you out entirely
thank you
they knew the code as soon as it popped
up they just put in the code and kept
watching
[Music]
we did we didn't have the heart to tell
their mom
we didn't want to rat him out or
anything you know but
this is hilarious that they just knew
the code it didn't do anything
and it was sad because they
the other the other part of this too
and I I know she doesn't watch My Stream
So I'm not gonna like they were
I would say they were rude they were not
they were not great kids
the mom did not notice at all
they they were
didn't want to talk to us they didn't
want to
they didn't want to do anything with us
they just wanted to be on their iPad and
that was it that's all they wanted to do
and I I found it concerning it was weird
for me
like we took them to
um
we took them to it wasn't a zoo but it
was kind of like a zoo where you could
like hang out with horses and stuff they
wanted to leave as soon as we got there
and [ __ ] moaned and complained the
entire time
it was sad
they just like kept asking to get back
on their iPad so I found it very
concerning at least for them I know
that's not the case for everybody
but man
I I can only think that a lot of kids
are the same way
oh this was my cousin's kids eight and
five-year-old
an eight-year-old and a five-year-old
they need to get bullied a little bit
I'm not saying that exactly
oh come on
can we just not have any type of Archer
here for once there we go
and there's a lot of good things about
social media Dora there really is I
think there's a lot of bad with it that
is not being addressed
and it's like purposely trying to mind
[ __ ] you
so that you stay on the apps longer you
know what I mean it's totally doing it
on purpose to make you do it to make you
stay on the app for as long as possible
and they put billions of dollars into
making sure you stay on the app as long
as possible
okay
yeah I'm not sure about things like
autism and stuff like
I'm not I don't know what that's like
obviously
but just for just for these kids it was
just a couple kids like maybe it's not
as bad as I'm thinking it is but
I don't know maybe you guys have
the same experiences
my dad's a high school teacher too and
he says that the kids are just so like
my like he calls them mindless zombies
like they just don't think about
anything they just don't care about
literally anything but what's on their
phone
ow
stop it
oh my God she screamed oh I can upgrade
now cool
my best friend's little brother is an
iPad okay I already read that I mean
there's a time and place for Tech but
having them raise your kids to use an l
I think that's a big part of it is like
they're using the iPad and the phone
like the parents are giving them that so
early
to distract them
right
so that they're not like I don't know
running around and being annoying and
they don't have to like watch their kids
you should start making videos about
political
oh God
uh I don't know if I want to do that man
I like talking to you guys about it
my ex-wife what's this [ __ ]
yeah I'm sorry about that but there I
it just doesn't seem like kids are being
parented by their parents anymore
they're being parented by
the iPad and the parents that age don't
know how brainwashing it is to do that
you know they have no idea
so they just let them do it because
technically their kids are uh
their kids are behaving quote unquote
right
because they're not I don't know doing
what I did was a kid when I was a kid
like going around and
riding my bike into places I shouldn't
you know being being a a kid
instead they're inside on their iPad and
their phone way too early
I didn't get a phone until I was like in
high school and when I got a phone it
was not uh what it can do now it was
literally like I could call my parents
or the police or whatever
so I didn't even care about it
I'm not ratting out my cousin I just I
noticed this with them I really did
here's the other thing I didn't even
tell you guys
oh cool we're at the Haley tree
um I have another cousin who they have
in in another eight-year-old kid and
they don't allow her to have a phone or
an iPad they gave her something called a
firefly
I'm 27. I'll be 28 in March
um
she's not allowed on the she's not
allowed on YouTube she's not allowed on
Tick Tock any of this stuff she is such
a good [ __ ] kid and I'm not saying
that only social media and stuff is like
ruining kids Minds like I think it's a
big part of it but also
this my other cousins actually like pay
attention to her and parent her and and
do things with her instead of just
allowing them to be on social media or
the internet all the time
I just there was a huge difference like
she was much more social with us she
wanted to do everything was uh with us
um
she just had like better awareness
so I think like once you become an adult
you you can absolutely use social media
in in a phone an iPad and enjoy like
YouTube and twitch and whatever it is
right but
I
mean
go watch the video I recommended earlier
that Tick Tock is destroying Society
there is a segment in there that is
actually disturbing
where um
it's so [ __ ] sad man I don't know if
I want to say it on stream
it like there are little girls out there
who are live on tick tock
showing off their bodies to really weird
people
and they're just letting it happen
because they can't moderate all the
people trying to do it it is disgusting
I'm pretty sure it's called Tick Tock is
destroying Society like go watch it when
you have the time
it it made me want to get off the app
completely it is gross
not to sour the move but that was a big
part of it man
and and just like those kids who are
just mindlessly scrolling on Tick Tock
they're gonna come across that [ __ ]
they're gonna think it's normal
I'm distracted obviously
no it's definitely illegal for girls to
do that ATO
like they're clearly underage they're
just lying about it and they do get
banned
if they're caught but it there's so much
of it for the reasons we've been talking
about
okay Blasphemous played cool
um that it's impossible to moderate it's
it's just all over it like
they couldn't possibly ban the problem
is why are so many of them doing it
and then why are people like okay the
people are disgusting and gross and
whatever that's why they're wanting that
to happen
it's just so disturbing
yeah musically was Tick-Tock before it
was Tick Tock right
we are getting off topic this is getting
way too deep right now for sure just go
give that video a watch
they see grown-ups do it they see it on
these platforms
that they shouldn't see it
50 and grown strong I grew up with my
BW TV and that ended at 10 pm first
computer when I was 10.
working as a pen tester I have zero and
never had any social media except my
YouTube channel
and you're probably happier because of
it man
dude those things hit so hard
I am streaming today until we get this
done
that's my plan
we need to find two more great rooms and
then we can do the Final Bosses
uh oh whoops
that's a miss
no I was looking at chat
and I pressed y dude [ __ ] my bad
I have to get preachy social media and
the whole idea of going viral promises
significance purpose fulfillment uh we
give anything to those kinds of we give
anything for those kinds of things
it's uh
there's definitely other ways to find
that stuff without it being online you
know
like my Pursuit
of this job
I had to make a lot of sacrifices
is that a big boy item I don't think so
ran a dog
that worked out really well
bruh you were harder than the tyranna
dog like actually
what color is your Bugatti
wow you are
freaking insane
praise the seven are my alerts just not
working anymore
but thank you Andrew
thanks for all the super chats today and
all the members guys thank you
I don't know what's going on
YouTube's
[ __ ] is weird sometimes
sorry to say
and today it's a parent's fault if
you're too lazy to take care of your
child and just give them a phone when
they cry they'll grow up wanting the
phone I totally agree
couldn't agree more
uh let me reload everything
come on YouTube
they're punishing us right exactly
oh we've had notifications all day it'll
probably pop up at some random ass time
it seems to break
a lot
okay we're almost to Millennia
which like she has to give us a great
Rune right
I would imagine
we gotta beat Loretta first
what's up Hugo
foreign s
too much seven spam
play more
live Shield
can I not use it's [ __ ] Moog oh God
it's the other Vogue
foreign
I can't use my mimic what the hell
ow
77777
did I ban this person
that is a lot of spammy in my guy
hey there it is but that's a different
one
more
food
77
00
[Music]
that was a donation that's not even a
super chat it was a donation
thanks for the dollar Akira more got
best feet waifu 77777
I guess YouTube's broke
I'm just gonna ban this person there's
no way you don't have the uh
the know-it-all to know to not spam like
that
like come on bro
is there not a uh why am I all the way
over here
I could try something to try and fix it
um I remember trying it before and it
didn't work
oh I didn't unlock the shortcut you're
right
forgetting where that is
mean jelly
it was back where I was
I'm lost it's over here I got it I got
it I got it
you like that skip
Pro Gamer by the way
do you want kids not right now no
not at all
that might change someday but I don't
uh I don't intend to have kids right now
I think the world they're being put into
is not good
I would rather wait until they're in a
better place
I will say like I don't if right now the
state of the USA I would not have kids
in this country
if I live somewhere in Europe I probably
would
have bread
and now I can use my mimic interesting
it's weird
I mean it's the Ukraine and Russia I
wouldn't call it the all of Europe
what the [ __ ] is my mimic doing
there we go
foreign
that's where I live killer
foreign
I live near St Louis
hey there it is
777
777
yeah is he immune
trillion 777
777 million 777
it looks like yesterday
thank you Andrew
it only took like 10 minutes work
oh now the Bots are here it's all going
to [ __ ] guys
now
big Bonk
die foul bot there we go
wow a sword key well
oh wow a sword key oh my God
where'd you say you live killer what
part
live in Missouri I live south of the
city
I live to the West
like 30 minutes outside of St Louis
yeah yeah Jefferson City I don't live
near there
I don't want to say exactly where I live
are you guys gonna be like where is he
hello
it is a small world
Jacksonville Florida
I lived in Miami and Orlando for a
couple years when I was a pro golfer
not a fan of Florida
I do have a plan I have a plan in my
head yeah what's your address
the plan in my head is to live uh
uh in Norway or Finland by the time I'm
35. that's my like my life goal
s
Florida is caled but 10 times worse what
I'm saying dude
Ian man
my address is the same as your mom's
excellent
please don't rock me thank you
item nope
no I don't speak Norwegian I want to
learn though before I go there
it's kind of a major major goal
that likely won't happen but I would
like it if it did
Copenhagen Denmark is ideal yep
I've also heard Portugal is really
beautiful my aunt and uncle are there
right now
I'm gonna kind of get their opinion on
Portugal
before I do
I have to go visit all these places
before I want to live there first you
know
gotta visit
he's silly not to
Austria
I gotta take like a month and just go to
Europe
getting a lot of Heroes runes right now
as I say that
oh what the [ __ ]
what the hell are you doing
I was not expecting that
what the [ __ ] how
what is he doing there what
ah
come to Mars right
probably by the time I'm 35 we'll all be
living there
who is this right here
clearly a face
where am I going
it's the mini boss from the tower
you're right
did that one not have a health meter I
don't think it did
holy damage [ __ ] Christ
foreign
get me down
I'm from the Netherlands and Europe is a
decent place to live in but definitely
don't over hype yourself it's not
perfect uh yeah I know
neither is America
nowhere is perfect
I gotta see what's in there huh
hell yeah
get out of here
Celestial Dew
neat
America's that bad
it's not good
I don't like it
yep let's all moved to Antarctica
it's a great idea
all right
oh Joy's barking Joy is not happy right
now
holy slow what the [ __ ]
they see me rolling the hay tan
troll trying to catch me rolling dirty
watch me rolling dirty catch me rolling
dirty
I should have died
aha
should have died
that's the Rock God
I was like who's that
please let this be a normal stream with
adt's chat no way huh
what are you talking about
I've been streaming a lot
like a ton
yeah we're close to melania's area now
[Music]
I'm at the Halo tree
you guys don't know where this is
oh there's somebody outside
got it
we have already fought plastidus ax
he was at the Moonlight altar
heard me I don't make me take Rick's
helmet young man what are you talking
about I am so confused
we already fought the Eldon Beast it was
where God for usually is we already
fought Melania
he was where golden Godfrey is
we already fought radagon he was where
the golden or the godskin noble is
I'm just talking out my ass okay
I think it's Gotta Be Gideon
It's gotta be Gideon bro
we've already fought Godfrey and horalu
let's see
oh it's the golden Godfrey that's so
lame
I forgot your thing
we bought fought both malekets
better give me a great room brother
oh there's gonna be two here by the way
because there's two phases
so it could be Gideon next
uh-huh went right into it idiot
maybe not because the music changed
that was dumb
this is actually cool with the music
oh you dirty oh
foreign
there it goes
all right who we got
nothing
oh come on
that's like glitch
join myself and King that is
grilled cheese grilled cheese grilled
cheese grilled cheese grilled cheese
grilled cheese grilled cheese grilled
cheese grilled cheese grilled cheese
grilled cheese
what was Melania saying [ __ ] that [ __ ]
thank you Andrew
thanks for all the super chats man
you guys are very kind
grilled cheese indeed
lore
I think I have Michael his needle can I
turn this in
nope
wait I totally do
my totes do
be a key item
Maybe
we did get a great Rune though
we got melania's great Rune we're only
looking for reichards now
I guess I don't have it
for realsies oh there it is Nicholas
needle subdues a once accepted frenzied
Flame
so I already have the thing
that I give to this that I get from this
thing that's right
okay
but we want to do flame of frenzy ending
so we can't use it at the placidusax
fight
interesting
did you do the pantheon of blood what do
you
mean
what are you talking about
we talking about
dude we already fought uh Moog
yeah you use that in the place to do sex
Arena
I guess we wouldn't no
it would we'd already do that
yeah we already went to moog's Palace
guys
we already fought him
easel River shaded Castle
ruins Drew precipice where is that
wait what did you guys say make a
you thought of making a short vid of
moments from the stream I
I find it hard to make content that
isn't
lore videos
which is why I haven't made one in like
a month
I'm very lured out at this point I'm
almost done making one that uh about
radagon
but
you know that's why I've been streaming
mostly like YouTube's algorithm is so
insanely like
yo what up Johnny uh
like you do the thing that that got you
views and you stick to that thing or it
just
aches
you know what I'm saying
I don't think I have the best lore
videos at all that goes to smoke town or
vati thousand percent in my opinion
one of those three bosses has the last
great room
Christmas is magma worm
oh
over here
in the middle area here we haven't even
gone there
if I go this way
who is this oh
screams shirtless
how would that help me man
doesn't Nicholas need a place to do size
break his character
break his character no
I would that break his character now I
need to go uh
this is fine
well I appreciate that Tommy thank you
best narrating sounding voice
guys
come on
come on
luvati's voice dude
are you kidding me right now
let's go did we fight God of Royal yet
we should do that
can I jump down from here no
come on man
yeah it's it's literally ASMR
I made one larvit took a bit of content
from a Reddit post some [ __ ]
are on my neck so I had to delete that
vid
uh did you credit
the Reddit posts you took it from
remember even my son chose your voice
okay that's true
what about a lore video based on the
Elden ring randomizer
uh I don't know how that would work
AGT ASMR
sexy manager thank you all right who are
you
balls the ground
balls
stop running
excellent grafted balls is down
grafted balls
Eldon beasts the grafted and his brother
balls
didn't credit in the vid because I
edited [ __ ] myself didn't know how to
edit well but I gave them
but I gave them description of the vid
um I mean if you put it in the
description that should be fine
reddit's not very friendly in my
experience so I wouldn't think too much
of it man
varnish these nuts boys
yeah but we want to do the friend the
flame of frenzy ending so
we don't want to get rid of the flame of
frenzy
chat voted on it
okay
other excellent
mimics here was encountered yes
we did see the
the lands between my balls oh God
we're gonna steer clear of all of that
guys
I never seen body Dodge like you though
hey appreciate it man
if I'm impressing you with my dodging I
must be doing something right
says the guy who needs me to just dodge
is uh the Shaded Castle boss fight here
considered a main boss
might as well go do it
it's a pretty cool area
if he is a main boss we haven't
encountered him yet
Edgar the Briar
uh-oh
okay he's he's eating he's eating my
balls run
man gobbled my balls dude the hell
I have no idea I'm going off what Chad's
telling me
I don't think this would be considered a
main boss but maybe
guard Bears eldenbeast Elmer godskin Duo
sir Gideon Fierce Champions those are
Shard bears
Edgar of the golden order
let's go see what this uh thing in his
chest is over here it's usually a pretty
important item
foreign
oh that was not worth this situation
awesome I love that for me
yeah we went to the South castle castle
mourn yeah
we went there days ago
that I don't think that could have been
a worse [ __ ] person for that
hey have fun at the gym Andrew
appreciate you being here man thank you
go to the gym later today too after
stream at some point
there's definitely something in his spot
by Angel River that's true that's very
true
we will have to go check that out
yeah dragon skin freaking replace Placid
Deuce ax
what the
it's like what the hell could that be
eth coffee of the day huh that is
caffeine
that is a lot of caffeine
dragon-skinned soldier of knock Stella
in the golden order that's a long title
oh we're taking technically looking for
at this point is Melania or reichard's
great Rune that's it
when DLC
drops and we find out cocoon person
ain't make a look
you I'm gonna be everywhere going I
[ __ ] told you guys
I've gotten for that video
so much
I have gotten so much [ __ ] for that
video
foreign
item in there bro
of the Briar excellent
give me that butthole
there it is
that's all we need baby
thank you Andrew I appreciate you man
thank you
that must have been great timing
all right where is this legendary item
you guys are talking about
what's the lore
um
Melania is your mom that's the lore
are you guys talking about
oh
no I thought my video was valid too on
mikola not being uh
in the Cocoon
but it doesn't matter
people believe what they believe and
they will [ __ ] on me to the ends of the
Earth if it's not what they think
what a rotten thing to say about
someone's mom I like your use of rotten
there
Michelob could be behind the glowing
door and earphill near the grace
and behind the archery Avatar yeah
guys where where is this item you're
talking about I've never seen a
legendary item here
I'm confused is it in here
oh right here
wow
the golden order Greatsword hey we can
we can beat the game now
let's go do it dude
we have all the great roots
this is if we get DLC
I have a feeling that they might not
make a DLC
yep it's open guys
it's open
it's time
we have not seen Gideon he will
definitely be one of these last two I
think
I don't know who else we've missed
it's time to fulfill the prophecy of the
stream title
thanks for being here this might take a
while we'll see
let's beat this thing
I don't give a [ __ ] about faith weapons
I ain't even gonna watch who we got
okay Loretta of the golden order
Epic
I actually really like this fight
foreign
I'll take that to my face
get annihilated
thank you
what is that delay I've never seen her
do that
I have never seen her do that weird ass
flippy flip
no DLC well goodbye unsubbing you're
wrong never talking to you ever again
okie dokie buddy
they'll make DLC guys
they might not though
that answer
is that good enough for you
should be good
stop it
Melton
hello
foreign
ition here
good
big damage opportunity
[Music]
what the
thank you
damn
should be a second phase
it's a horse
okay it has to be Gideon right
unless Gideon isn't a main boss
place your bets
no I could beat her without mimic for
sure
patches
he could be at Angel that's true
all right let's see
Eldon Gideon offner
thick
oh he's melting bro
this kind of works huh
like imagine we were battling for the
Elden ring here
he could [ __ ] heal
spit your ass down bro
it's me and you
this is actually kind of cool I like
this
okay
okay
that was game right there
there it is
we did it
we got a [ __ ] painting at the end of
the game are you kidding me
you gave me a painting
laughs
nice
literal painting dude
boys
it is time
big runes though
it's the greatest [ __ ] painting in
this world
it's time to burn it all down
time to burn it all
become the Lord of frenzied Flame
[Music]
this ending is so [ __ ] cool
go find Rick I'm not gonna run around to
try and find freaking Rick dude
he's out there in some random ass
irrelevant dungeon
let's go
yeah we did the tutorial area it was a
rune bear
that replaced them
dude holy [ __ ] OBS crashed for a second
are we good now
did we die
okay we're good we're good we're good
burn it all down
[Music]
I'm burning down all social media that's
what I did
uh we gotta get yelled at
yeah we pissed her off
we definitely pissed her off
this scene right here is so [ __ ]
awesome
rip torrent
Lord or frenzied Flame
why did her voice disc glitch
did you hear that
I will seek you as far as you may travel
to deliver you what is yours
damn bro death
what a fun series
if you guys haven't done randomizer I
highly recommend it it is so much fun
it kind of changes the game you don't
you don't know what to expect around
every corner just like when you first
played it it's so fun
all right
W's in chat
we did it
GG
hello
hello
W's I think that's what we do on YouTube
we w'd it up
thanks for being here boys
and girls
thanks for the super chats thanks for
chatting in general makes it a lot more
fun
for all the support I really appreciate
it you guys are great
I love streaming on YouTube
it is so much fun
every time
so
I don't know what I'm gonna do next
when it comes to the streams
[Music]
I think we should continue bloodborne
for sure
I don't know what I want to do first
yep why didn't you dodge
exactly exactly
I definitely want to do Dark Souls 3. I
will never play Dark Souls 2 again
Elden ring reforged what's that
is that another mod
I think that's what I want to do Cameron
if if metal is down to do it
I would love to continue the random the
seamless co-op with metal
I think that would be really fun
[Music]
but we'll see if she wants to do that
still
it makes the game way harder [ __ ] maybe
I'll look into it
um but we'll figure something out guys
I appreciate every single one of you for
being here thanks for hanging out with
me today
thanks for watching and everything
you know if you missed anything you can
always go back and watch these on the
channel there's a playlist for the
randomizer
for every stream that we did they're all
in videos now if you want
um I'll check that out Mr GB that seems
cool
um
we'll see what we do next
I do want to take a couple days and work
on a video that I'm almost done writing
which has to do on the lore of radagon
so hopefully you guys like that
um I can probably get that done in a
couple days I think so we'll see
anyway
appreciate all of you like I said
go eat some grilled cheese
and goodbye thanks for being here guys
peace out peace out I will see you all
again soon
bye bye bye